I'm not gonna lie to you I had a whole
intro planned about how a movie called
smile just alludes to it being a
complete horror creep Fest but then I
realized dude it's October 1st this is a
horror movie Halloween intro baby
[Music]
all right so smile is written and
directed by first time filmmaker Parker
Finn he's done a couple of shorts but
this is his big move into a feature film
it follows a psychologist played by
Sophie bacon who has a patient who's
like I see smiling people everywhere but
they're not real people and then she you
know horribly kills herself so now so
see Bacon's character starts seeing
smiling people so you're like was it
contagious is it a real thing is it in
her head and that's part of the
greatness of smile the fun of being like
is this all in her head is it actually
happening it's fun to try to piece it
together but you realize it's neither
here nor there whether it's happening in
her head or happening in real life it is
happening to her so it's real to her
thus it's real to you it's kind of
brilliantly executed now Susie bacon
carries this film this is her film in
fact I can't think of a scene that she's
not in and she's selling it because she
does have to sell a lot she has to sell
the fact that this lady is being
tormented so the audience has to
empathize with her but not really know
what's going on either when people doubt
her in the room you have to be on her
side and to be like look idiots this is
real then when she starts seeing things
you have to be like maybe it's in your
head it really does take you on a roller
coaster of emotions and she is at the
Forefront of selling it to you great
support cast too Cal pens in it as bit
more than a cameo Jesse T Usher from the
boys Kyle gallner because he's my guy
around 20 years ago Rousseau is watching
Smallville he played Bart Allen I was
like something memorable about that dude
we all have that person right we noticed
an actor and we're like he's going
places and they do and you're like I
could be an agent I do like how this
movie does blend the lines between
horror and Thriller they're very close
in concept but usually when you watch a
movie it is horror or thriller this
movie has some epic scares too it does
have some jump scares of my least
favorite parts of the movie but in
execution it is still the thing that's
there to scare you that scares her it's
not some douchebag all like
hey what's up how's it going so uh what
are you doing later right it's not jump
scares like that there is a bit more
payoff with these scares in the sense
that it is building tension and then
tension does explode but my favorite
parts were the anxiety that came before
that she's staring down the hallway into
a dark room and you're like don't do
that just stays on that dark spot for
longer than is comfortable or maybe it
was just a lighting thing something in
the background that looks like someone's
just standing or sitting there I feel
like Parker Finn has a concept of what
freaks people out most and how to really
tweak a setting in a house to optimize
that fight or flight that you're gonna
feel I will say there were a couple of
cartoony elements both visually and
conceptually Visually at a point there's
some CGI that starts entering the mix
and it looks like CGI it's like ah first
time filmmaker psychological Thriller
budget but now psychological Thriller
budget has to accommodate horror Vibes
CGI horror vibe that is you know so you
start you see it and conceptually the
main character's sister is just
cartoonish [ __ ] like to the point
where she has this husband this guy
she's married to and this guy is such a
wet blanket like yes ma'am I'm sorry
she's like get the [ __ ] out of here he's
like I'm sorry I'm like oh my gosh she's
horrible to him granted the film does
deal with childhood trauma I imagine
it's supposed to be that's what her
childhood trauma is leading to in her
adult life very unhealthy Behavior but
the movie never really addresses that
just comes across his house smack the
dumb husband around because it's funny
it was a weirdly out of place thing the
film should have done something with it
but in the end smile it's one of those
dark horses that comes out not really on
my radar and it comes out to start the
Halloween film season off of the
Vengeance it was a great Thriller
satisfying horror you're asking the
questions the film is begging you to ask
and you're asking them because you want
to go on this journey and figure out
what's happening and that it's a really
fun investigative film as well don't
watch the trailer I I like the fact that
I didn't see the trailer I knew nothing
about this movie I was going in cold
trailer shows a bit much there were a
couple scenes in particular that I I
didn't see what was coming but the
trailer shows you what is coming if I a
trailer you're not going to know it at
the time but you're going to watch the
movie and you'll be like oh that's the
setting with oh I know what's going to
happen I do hope people watch this one
it's a perfect film to bring your
friends in on after you've seen it
picture it Halloween party everyone
brings their movies you're like smile
you've seen it it's a room full of
people like no I haven't seen no no no
you're like perfect cannot wait to see
you all experience it that's the kind of
vibe this film has for me it's not every
day I give a pass on the jump scares
this movie's a solid fun time no alcohol
required all right so smile have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
hey what's up how's it going so uh what
are you doing later